basically the idea is to push people toward imagining what they've never imagined
and feeling what they've never felt before
he's an old friend of all of ours, so I'd like you all to welcome.. Timothy Leary
yeah
I for one, am overjoyed to be here
this is one of those special, special evenings
that we will all treasure
Terence McKenna means a great deal to me
I would say he's one of the 5 or 6 most important people on the planet
I can't even think of any others..
short term memory loss, but..
Terence and I keep meeting in the most wonderful, mythic, adventurous places
I was doing a wild tour
through Germany about a year ago
we came to Heidelberg and we were being guested by
some people that came right out of Hermann Hesse..
I mean wizards and gnomes and you know that sort of thing, Heidelberg!
and there was Terence McKenna
and it was just so perfectly Hesse, Journey To The East, yeah..
and so we meet again here tonight
you know..
I was talking to Terence backstage before we began
and we both agree that what he'll be saying tonight has been said
over and over again
at all those high moments in human history
when those who have gone within
and understood about the brain
and the inner treasures
we all come back and pretty much say the same thing
but the problem is though that once you say it, you know
you can't go on saying it and saying it and saying it
and when Terence came along a few years ago
and was saying what I've been trying to say
but naturally better, upgraded, up to date
I was so overwhelmed with gratitude
and I publicly thank you for that, Terence
by the way the role that Terence is playing right now
is one that takes not only vision, but it also takes fucking courage
we were saying backstage that
that Terence and I are a
small group of philosophers
who make our living not in the Ivory Tower
-to call it living, but uh..-
just speaking it
chatting it, raving it..
ranting it
and no one has ever done it with more
poetry and elegance than the speaker tonight
I'm gonna say one more thing and then
we will have what we've all been waiting for
Terence reminds us that
all human wisdom, all energy comes from
our beloved synergetic partners
the vegetable queendom
it all comes from the plants
now a round of applause
to the vegetables!
now we all know
that the human body, we have to have food
it comes from vegetables
we've used vegetables over the years
the essence of vegetables in the form of wood
to develop fire, gas, oil, so forth
but what we forget
and what we look to Terence for tonight
is to be reminded that
plants have given us an even more important gift
they give us the gift of vision
they give us the illumination
and throughout human history
they're at the ease and the pandoras
usually it's a woman
who takes this wonderful vegetable
and gives it to humanity and says
be illuminated
and now for our illumination and our pleasure
please join me in welcoming Terence McKenna
well I wanna thank Tim
that was a wonderful introduction
I'm sure I wouldn't, I know I wouldn't be here tonight
if it weren't for Tim Leary
he was the pathfinder
he cut the way through the woods
he gave us all permission to be
very much the people that we are tonight
and it's wonderful that one Irishman can hand it on to another
and that we can keep it in the bardic tradition
wonderful
I can hardly believe I'm here
I made it past the Camaro Raffle
I survived the offer for reconstructive cosmetic surgery
and I've had my smart drugs for this evening, so..
glad to be here!
well until a few minutes ago I thought that this was a
45 minute gig, so..
you get to see grace under pressure this evening
naturally I'm kidding, it doesn't matter how long it goes
we could never get to the bottom of this stuff
nor would we wish to, I think
by coincidence merely, I became 45 yesterday
so..
sort of a good moment to do some summing up
so in thinking about this talk
and knowing as I did who would be here
I thought that I would sort of
orient the theme toward distilling the psychedelic mind
which is a way of
talking about the psychedelic mind
but also
trying to, uh..
considering the amount of money you paid for this session
give you the entire shtick in one fell swoop
so that you would never have to
attend a Terence McKenna lecture
or workshop again
you can just move past that
turn the page on that kind of thing in your life
with me in the studio is Terence McKenna
author, lecturer, explorer and philosopher
Terence is the co-author with his brother Dennis McKenna
of a book called 'The Invisible Landscape: Mind, Hallucinogens, and the I Ching'
he is also the co-author of 'Psilocybin: Magic Mushroom Grower's Guide'
he is the author of a computer program called Timewave Zero
and he is the co-founder
and president of an organisation called
Botanical Dimensions
which devotes itself to saving
botanical plants
used in shamanistic traditions throughout the world
welcome Terence
it's a pleasure to be here
it's a pleasure to have you here
well I think the most profound cultural development
it is possible to make the case that language itself
is an ability, that was coaxed out of an
evolving primate species
by virtue of the fact
that there were hallucinogenic plants
in the diet of that creature
you see, psilocybin has been shown in low doses
to actually increase visual acuity
well at the stage of evolution where
human beings encountered psilocybin mushrooms
we were essentially, baboon-like, pack-hunting, hoards of velt-living creatures in Africa
in that situation, a compound which increases visual acuity
will give a tremendous adaptive advantage
to the animals that are including it in their diet
and those animals not including it in their diet
will be quickly eliminated by the process of natural selection
from the evolutionary scenario
so it's possible to argue
that this mind manifesting quality
of the psychedelics
actually conferred an evolutionary advantage
on certain primates
who then were able to bootstrap themselves
to higher and higher states of reflective self awareness
this may lie behind the very early coincidence of
cattle, goddesses and mushrooms
in the apparent obsessions of early man
as reflected by the cave paintings on the Algerian plateau
and in southern France and Spain
we always find the notion of the mystery
circa 18 thousand years ago
connected with the idea of cattle
and we always find the cattle connected with the notion of the Great Goddess
now it may be that the hidden and third member of this trinity
was a hallucinogenic mushroom of some sort
we've got only about 2 minutes left
but I wonder what the connection, I don't quite see it
between the mushroom, the cattle and the Goddess
the mushrooms grow in the manure of the cattle
when the hunting packs of early primates
followed along behind the cattle,
they inevitably encountered the mushroom
ate it, had their visual skills thereby increased,
bred more readily therefore and survived more easily than their non-mushroom eating cousins
and so the eating of mushrooms and the development of higher aspects of consciousness
including self-reflection, were thereby enforced
leading to the conclusion that it was actually
a symbiotic relationship between early primates
and these hallucinogenic plants
that laid the basis for the appearance of what we call human beings
well Terence McKenna, this is
a very interesting discussion
you seem to be suggesting that our evolution, I suppose
from the animal kingdom into the human kingdom itself
was catalysed or triggered by our encounter with these hallucinogenics
yes, we are an ape with a symbiotic relationship
to a mushroom
and that has given us
self-reflection, language, religion
and all the spectrum of effects that flow from these things
and one can only wonder how
these hallucinogens might affect our future evolution as well
they've brought us to this point, and as we make our relationship to them conscious
we may be able to take control of our future evolutionary path
in the 120 years from 1500 to the beginning of the 30 years war
Europe was caught in a number of conspiracies and political intrigues
directed toward moving Europe toward a magical and alchemicly based society
the protestant princes of the northern league of Germany
especially Frederick the Elector Palatine came to culminate this movement
but its roots lie further back in the 1580s of the 16th century
it was in this period that the english astrologer, astronomer, mathematician, navigator
and expert of espionage, John Dee
launched his famous and mysterious mission to Bohemia
a little-known incident in european history
which holds clues to understanding the faith and evolution of modern science
and the nature of a lost world of magical and alchemical thinking
that once claimed the attention of the european imagination
John Dee
the greatest mind of the Elizabethan era
friend of Queen Elizabeth
colleague of Sir Philip Sidney
converser with angels
mathematician par excellence
determined under the influence of the mysterious Edward Kelley
that he was to be the center of an alchemical renaissance
and a secret society that would lay the groundwork
for the continuation of the dream of Austria
the dream built around the Elizabethan Queen, Elizabeth I
he associated himself intensely with the Arthurian mythical and mystical side
of the Elizabethan idea of British Empire
he was a Welshman, like the Queen, he was so intensely devoted too
and like her, he shared the renaissance mood of saturnian melancholy
a collector of books,
a builder of scientific instruments,
a composer of codes and cyphers
fascinated with alchemy
Dee was both the figure of the introspective melancholic
and the world-planning, empire-building political visionary
Dee was under the patrionage of the Earl of Northtumberland
and it was Northtumberland who looted the catholic monestaries at the time of Henry VIII
we have reason to believe that John Dee had virtual Carte Blanche in selecting
manuscripts from those libraries that interested him
not only was Dee a scholar of the classics
and the magical past
but he was an intimate friend with some of the great movers and shakers of his own time
particularly Sir Philip Sidney and the entire catorioue of poets and artists
who had gathered themselves around Elizabeth, Austria to celebrate her reign
and to make of her, the paradigmatic sovereign of Europe that Dee believed led the way
toward the establishing of a universal alchemical monarchy
it was essentially a poetic enterprise
as alchemy always is
Merlin
in the Arthurian legends has come down to us
basically disguised as John Dee
the image we have of Merlin is Dee's image
So, Dee possessed an enormous power over the imagination of his contemporaries
they were in awe of his learning
perhaps we are the naive ones
perhaps we too quickly assumed that we had understood all there was to know about matter
after all, even to this moment
we cannot locate the seat of the imagination
in matter
we cannot trace the evolution of a human thought or hope
it's almost as though the alchemists
through their humility, had a deeper insight
into the workings of the world
than we have achieved today
this is ground zero for the Rosicrucian Enlightenment
standing here,
in the alchemical laboratory
of the palace in Heidelberg
we are essentially at the center of the alchemical hopes of the Rosicrucian Enlightenment
it was here in the years before the adventure in Bohemia,
that Frederick's alchemists, astrologers and suit-sayers
toiled directly under the King's observation and control
here came Michael Maier
Heinrich Khunrath
the great names of alchemy
it's entirely possible that John Dee was in this room
it's entirely possible that Edward Kelley
stood were I am standing now
it's almost impossible to conceive of the hopes and the fantasies
and the labours
and the dreams
that have been generated by and are centered on
this room and the objects in it
this is the last alchemical laboratory in the world
to fully function before the rise of modern science
and these tools in many ways reflect
the internal cosmology of the man and woman who used them
this, for example, a typical alchemical distillery
is called the pelican
another example of the colourful nature of alchemical vocabulary
it's called the pelican because it is associated with the myth of a bird which plucks blood from its own breast
the prima materia
feces, black coal, charcoal, salt nitrate
heated in here
brought to a high temperature, a fevered colouric state
rises into the higher emporium of the vessel
and there, rarified, it condenses
liquifies
and flows down into the cooler domain of the child of the pelican
here the essence is collected, the quint-essence
and always the hope was that
the next experiment, the next combination of materials
would yield the elixir vitae
the lapis philosophorum
the completion that the alchemists sought
and so all this fantastic apparatus
that we see around us
is really
not so much in the service of channeling liquids, gasses
but in the service of channeling spirit
out of matter
and into the higher realms
where it then can be refluxed,
recondensed
and the lapis philosophorum
the stone of the philosophers
the central mystery
brought to completion
the transformation of matter
into a universal panacea for the redemption of mankind
this was Dee's great passion
this was the overarching theme of his life
a deep, deep commitment
to the reformation of society
and a deep, deep exhaustion and rejection
of the values of Christendom that he saw betrayed all about him
and then by distillation
and then by coagulation
and then by concentration through firing
the alchemical body is brought to completion
these are processes that go on both within
the chemical retort, the alembic,
in the alchemist's laboratory
and they're processes which go on in the heart and mind
of the alchemist
one process dissolves
another process separates the dross,
the gross matter from the precious
another concentrates the subtle essence
another raises the subtle essence to another level of refinement
and over time
the great friend of the alchemist
this process of rarifaction
and growth
both metallic and psychological
both internal and external
both personal and impersonal
proceeds and feeds upon itself
and eventually, not through an illogic discernable to the scientific mind
there is a kind of miracle
the production of the stone
the union of spirit and matter
the fusion of these two contradictory aspects of the universe into a new and third thing
the quintessence
the rubedo
the lapis philosophorum
the aqua vitae
the nostre lapis philosophorum devici
one of the most famous of all alchemical axioms is
as above, so below
meaning always
that in every small part of reality
there is a tiny reflection
of the great over structure of reality
and in the larger structures are hidden the secrets of the smallest
and vice versa
we have unconsciously imbibed the ontology of science
where we have mind firmly separated out from the world
but in an earlier age
mind and matter were seem to be out loyed together throughout nature
and I think it's very interesting that at this very high-tech moment in our adventure
the plants return
and almost stand before us as a beacon
and a promise
they stand for absolute Tao
they stand
for the correct way
for life to relate to its environment
this is one of the most interesting new psychedelics in the world
this is salvia divinorum
and it is definitely one of the plants which will shape the next few decades of the new millenium
this is a coleus
it's ironic that these plants
which have been in our kitchens and in our windowsill flowerbeds for generations
turn out to contain psycho-active compounds as powerful as any known to science
these are not particularly interesting in terms of drugs
but they're certainly bizarre
climb up here, with me
this is one of the most interesting plants in the garden
this is Psychotria viridis
this is the plant which causes the vision
when taken with Ayahuasca
when taken as a liquid
the experience lasts about 4-6 hours
it's not as intense as smoking it
smoking it is the most intense experience
this side of the yawning grave
when I take psychedelics I always do it in a shamanic style
usually at night
usually alone
in nature, if possible
and then I watch
I pay very close attention
I use my mind as an alchemical vessel
for carrying out observations
on the union of spirit
my spirit, my personality
and matter
the physical matter
of the substance that I'm ingesting
building on western psychotherapy as elaborated by Freud and Jung
one view of what psychedelics are
is, it's the part of your mind that you'd rather not do business with
it's the memories of childhood neglect or abuse,
it's uh, repressed kinky fantasies
in other words, the Freudian idea of the unconscious
that somehow these are drugs which dissolve the boundary between conscious and unconscious mind
and then you can do excellerated psychotherapy
cause resistances have been pharmacologically overcome
that's one model
it's good as far as it goes, it just doesn't go far enough
then there's another model
which I would call the traditional or shamanic model
and it says
the cosmos is a series of levels
and these levels are connected by vertical routes of access
which can be thought of as simply flights through space,
or magical trees,
or magical ladders,
anyway, there's an image of ascent
and ordinary people exist on only one of these levels
but a shaman is not an ordinary person, a shaman is a superhuman person
who has the power of animal allies behind them
and they can go up and down in these elevators that move between levels
and they can therefore recover lost souls,
see social hanky panky, theft and adultery,
see the causes behind that,
see the causes behind disease
so forth and so on
that would be the traditional one
well, thinking about this from a mathematicians' point of view
an all-encompassing explanation that would explain how all these magical feats are done
is simply to suppose that the shaman is somehow able
to project his consciousness, his or her consciousness,
into a higher dimension
not metaphorically, as in 'Sylvester Stallone has many dimensions'
not metaphorically
but literally, as in 'One dimension, two dimensions, three dimensions and four..
then I have noticed that all of biology
not simply shamanism within the context of human society
but all of biology is, in a sense,
a conquest of dimensionality
that, as we ascend
the phylogeny of organic life,
what animals are, are a strategy for conquering space-time
and complex animals do it better than simpler animals
and we do it better than any complex animal,
and we, 20th-century people do it better than any people in any previous century
because we combined data in so many ways that they couldn't:
electronically, on film, on tape, so forth and so on